don't want no short dick man you got bad
breath you got bad style you are just
awful
ugly ugly ugly ugly that song was huge
dude yeah it was always short short man
on the radio on the radio so like just
change the whole list they made it about
height no no no no no no no
can't grab the can't grab the can't grab
this stuff on the High show
rank
hello hello hello hello
[Music]
hello
you know what I I in hate even though I
like the band
I hate when people act like this about
the Beach Boys my [__] god
hurting his voice so so bad yes wishes
he started an octave lower yeah yeah
yeah he has nowhere to go
impressionistic way oh this guy God only
knows right it's magic
up high and I'll tell you that's number
three the climax I'll tell you I'll tell
you top note is right there sure about
it and um well you gotta you gotta look
you gotta notice where these top notes
are because oh you gotta tell you about
the song that's that's the point of this
song sure about it it's not there it's
to bring it to me God only knows what
grips you're sure about it before it
lets you in on the message I don't know
I love how he talks through it yeah I
mean I mean that guy and also a little
fun fact if you know the golden ratio
that appears he is universe and
Renaissance paintings a nightmare to his
girlfriend you know yeah within this
verse but now number two this bass line
now here's the thing you need to know
about baseball if you have a d chord
probably going to be in a D in the bass
nine times out of ten D chord
really lets you know where yeah right
yeah yeah if you can go Cha-cha-cha
we're home but this starts D over a it's
wide open it's different it could go
anywhere and chooses to go up push
against gravity so many sandwiches
would usually go here but instead
it goes oh oh surprise himself
incredible irritable bowel syndrome
again
notorious even higher up you think so
much only drinks milk resolve eat
sandwiches but it doesn't goes back down
really and before a boat goes down again
Apparently one is great the magical
Debussy relaxing oh now we're just
relaxing now we're just relaxing he
falls asleep but in gravity concept the
chord hits his head on the camera's home
[Music]
that brings me to number one which is
the surprise
shits himself I mean every time I listen
to this song
surprise me I can't why do you still get
surprises
a million times and I'm figuring I'm
playing it right now and I have no clue
where it's gonna go but it's also so
inevitable like it has
surprising and inevitable like the best
of all art
um the best of all Arts so soothing but
it never lets us tell us oh it never
lets us come home what it is
son of a [__]
so magical
dude as long and it's as killers of the
flower moon right
this is the same length as killers of
the flower I don't know what that it's
the new Scorsese movie that's four hours
did this go viral I'm so not surprised
oh and then this stupid Tick Tock thing
at the end wow you know boom
what a guy huh
and then it just and then you've got
blown and it's magical but it's nice but
and there you go I don't know and then
you go up I don't only know and then
I'll be like what I dream of and then we
got there and then we there there's
actually beautiful what I dream about
you wow
Mr [__] Kelsey hit the clock oh dude
it's absolutely I hit the clock it's
absolutely crazy that that guy is a real
person and means all that
and they go here's the surprise dude
when people talk like that like art art
teachers talk about that music teachers
Any teacher of any of the Arts they're
it's just like we should get rid of art
you love it so much and so do I that's
why I'm here in this class that you're
teaching that's why I'm here watching
this ticket but I hate you so what gives
you love this art form I love this art
form that's why we're both here you're
expressing your love for this art form
but I hate you it's confusing is it yeah
it is confusing it's a little confusing
you know what let that guy love it I
think I love it he's got a great life
you know
um and that's what's up that's yet to be
seen yeah
uh what the frick uh it's May 28th today
is
menstrual menstrual hygiene day okay so
that means wash out your
and tomorrow is Memorial Day so it's
like you know that's two that's more
bang for your buck there you know yeah
it's a big one to clean out your hihu
and then also be in memoriam
well
about the soldiers right yeah don't be
in Memorial because then you will be
don't be a memoriam someone who's dead
yeah so but you can sign up for the
patreon patreon
dot com slash Lifeline luxury and that
means that June 4th sign up now and you
get the rip roaring episodes uh for the
patreon and
um you can go to chrisley.com also I am
on tour I will be in Tucson coming up
Pueblo Colorado Colorado Springs
Charlotte North Carolina uh Knoxville
Nashville a bunch of different places so
go to I'm gonna be in Canada go to
chrisley.com and get them tickets uh and
uh you got a merch we got the merch
Lifeline merch lifelinemerch.com
wear it love it go to bed with it and
kiss it share it make everybody you know
buy one first QVC guy if you want a
one-on-one session with your boy baby
baby
and Booyah I'll make your life better
make those appointments at mathilea.com
okay cool uh you can also hit the
hotline two one three uh 973-8095 or go
to watch lifeline.com to let send in a
video anyway how about how you said it
80.95 and it sounded so messed up that
No One's Gonna know the numbers well
hotline number is
213.973 oops
eight zero nine five the truth is we
would rather have people send in a video
so whoopsie so it's okay okay well so
there we go so you made it now now you
made it so more people are gonna call
the hotline not doing videos never wrong
that's a guy who's never allowed to
admit he's wrong
uh God only knows how I dream about and
then it goes you so it goes God only
knows what I and then it has a beautiful
dream about you right wow uh yeah okay
that's correct
um did you know yep probably that I'm uh
that's what you're gonna say play guitar
that um wrote it out today
corduroy
okay corduroy I've pretty much seen a
homeless guy do exactly what he did
um so yeah so all right well you got
corduroy on it I love corduroy don't you
corduroy yeah you don't you don't wear
jeans okay I don't wear jeans but I've
begun to wear at least other things on
my legs than corduroy pants so you used
to only wear corduroys correct now you
wear shorts it could be 105 degrees I
would wear corduroy pants not shorts but
I still want to do that however it's
just sometimes I'm getting older I get
too hot yeah I can't handle it so I put
on like a pair of really big baggy
shorts like it's 1998 and you like that
because because it feels good because
they'll breathe right no it's just I
guess yeah if there is a breeze but it's
like lighter your legs don't feel like
they're gonna melt
etc etc do you ever get uh shorts on and
Breeze goes on and it hits right in
between your nuggets and legs that
little area on either side and get the
air in there and then you look you
literally go like this
no
okay the grundle is where I imagined it
when you said it so whatever yes I'm
talking about
nut nuggets
lag
to each their own teach their own teach
his own teacher Zone teacher Zone
teachers would be a movie with Harrison
Ford welcome to the teacher Zone the
teacher Zone will be a movie with
Harrison Ford in 1999. are you saying
the teachers own or teachers own that
would be wood and then the teacher's own
would be with Christopher Walken okay
but you know the horror movie The Devil
zone is a movie with Harrison Ford
that's why I said it so I'm good with it
I'm good with that I'm good like that
I'm good with movies like that okay
right so I don't even know but I don't
think so no I think you were thinking of
you were thinking of the devil's own so
therefore you said the teacher's own
starring Harrison Ford what wow wow I
hate that yeah dude I said that because
of that because I would hate it no I
said that because of the devil's own oh
yeah okay yeah all right so anyway
I saw
uh our buddy David Sullivan in the show
Fatal Attraction I saw it how is the
show the show was bad in the beginning
and then it got good
so now and I'll tell you what David's
only in the beginning
it's not because of that I think it
might be no I think what he did is he
laid the groundwork that you had to and
then the show got good and it was
because of him but he's got a big head
and he's fat he's got a really big head
but here's the deal I watched that I
also watched
um uh that movie last night oh dude I
watched a movie called Rogue
agent what is that it shouldn't have
been called that shouldn't have been
called that no [__] I watch it because I
like the guy actor on it and the female
actor on it as well who are those people
who had better Bad actors Gemma are
archerton yeah she's great yeah she's
good and then the guy in it is
James Norton's regular who's that
it's a great movie they're great
Gemma what is she from she's just a
nothing specific
she's just like a good English actress
another good show and I can't think of
what the heck it was and I'm pissed it
must have been great this is way better
than I thought it would be it's about a
real guy who uh was pretended that he
was an MI5 uh Irish uh spy and he was
just basically manipulating everyone
and just saying he was a spy he was like
trust me I'm a spy just do what I said
and did he like his real guy Robert wash
a couple women yes you know I know about
this guy yeah yeah yeah Robert spring
nuts how nuts when you hear a story like
that yeah I just like who are these
people that believe this stuff you hear
stories like this all the time though
yeah and I thought about how if I was
trying to pretend I was a spy how it
would never because I was watching with
Chris and afterwards I said you know I'm
a spy right and she said no you're not I
said yes I am I started as a spy and I
went under cover as a comedian it just
turns out I got really good and now I
kind of do it and make a lot of money
doing it but I'm still a spy okay and
you're and I have missions to do and but
she didn't believe you no Kristen did
not believe me I think I got her too
late right yes
yeah unless you're like a really good
over six years and we have two kids so
yeah but do you have you seen true lives
yeah he does that
well she doesn't know he's a spy exactly
that's different but when he imagine
that he sat down and told her she'd be
like that you're not serious you're not
a spy right but that couldn't be more of
an opposite movie than what I said
because that's literally about the
opposite of that I'm saying you can keep
it secret for as long as Arnold did she
lies now I get it so it's like God only
knows and then the beautiful blood I see
with that and then here it comes we're
bringing it home without you okay
interesting yeah pretty interesting okay
cool well so I'm not a spy dude I know
that joke's on you guys I absolutely
when I was a kid I wanted like real
spiders spy Tech yeah all the with the
fingerprints oh yeah and the laser and
the hearing one yeah put the thing on
you could actually hear people from so
those things exist you can from far away
you can Zone in just like a long lens on
a camera and get the sound waves from
like someone talking super far away yep
and I want that oh so bad I would do
that to my neighbors all day all day
every day I would never come here I
would never leave the house I would
never do anything with my time except
listening to the conversations of people
who live near me voyeur
listen to your neighbors every day that
how enjoyable would that be to know what
everyone's talking about I don't care I
don't think I would like that okay
honestly you're a loser I'm not a loser
oh yeah it's much more of a loser to be
in behind your thing like you know
that's cool you control you have all the
power you can hear everybody you don't
have any power you're just listening
what if they said hey remember when I
killed somebody it's the worst killer
dude hey remember when I killed somebody
no hey remember how we killed that
person and we buried the body it so and
so Fairfax and behind the El Pollo Loco
dude oh man you know I'm kind of hungry
man let's go let's go get a six piece
dude
I will get the uh meal with the rice and
beans and just sir there's blood all
over you oh [__] uh
so anyway I watch a lot of great [__] on
TV all right man what a Segway of all
time do you no I don't watch yep TV the
only show I'm watching right now so I'm
better than you and that and I'm
surprised I haven't finished it because
I like it a lot and it's done is uh
servant that's the only show and even
that's over so I don't watch anything I
didn't watch the last season all right
well you watched all three of the first
Seasons oh I watch it dude I watch great
TV
and you know who's the best actress on
TV and well now it's over Lauren Ambrose
is so good in that dude she's the mom
the the I can't remember who it is the
red hair she was in six feet under she's
in so much [__] oh you like her huh yeah
she's so crazy in that show yeah like
she gets more and more and more crazy
yeah it starts out and she's already
insane it's great yeah yeah yeah
uh we gotta we gotta we gotta watch that
we gotta watch that that last season huh
wow so boring you know we gotta uh dude
so I'm dressing cute what the [__]
that's cute I'm dressing cute I walked
out of the the house today and Christian
was like you're really dressing a lot
cuter nowadays and I was like what
that's all of it a good thing to wear
what you're wearing right now I can't
always say that and be honest God only
knows what I dream and then and then
really wow what about not the words
God only knows what I dream you know
dude so I just been killing it just rip
roaring you know wow but um so anyway
with the clothes you've been killing
just I don't know man you want to go and
do a thing let's do a thing okay let's
do a thing
oh we see this guy hello Matt and Chris
one kid Harrington uh this is the update
for the friend on Facebook who was
getting threatened for money after he
shot oh yeah
random person
um so he took your advice so much hair
on your chicken with this person told
them I'm not gonna pay you anymore go
ahead and share it's gonna be bad and
they did
um they did share his nudes with his
entire friends list so friends family
everyone uh everyone there size wiener
real nice
um but I guess I should have given some
context in the last video his parents
are really religious uh strict religious
background could have used that he still
lives with them could have used it
Unfortunately they did not take too
kindly of this whole situation and they
kicked him out of their house oh that's
horrible and they actually disowned him
as well oh he's not serious
so you know he didn't lose any more
money but now he doesn't have a place to
live and he needs to rekindle his
relationship with his parents so no he
doesn't any advice would be appreciated
no he doesn't don't feel too bad I would
have given him the same advice
anyway thanks
just real quick
your parents
that guy not not Kit Harington but kit
harington's friend's parents yeah
are terrible people yeah okay those
people are terrible people and he
doesn't need to make amends with his
parents because they are terrible people
you know what they need to do is make
amends with him yeah he's already down
dude he's already down on the on he's on
the mat flat on his back and his parents
are like get out we disown you he's
already got his dick all over town yeah
he's he's doing bad enough dude how
about this dude send this to the guy
because it's that's brutal man you're uh
I I feel really I'm I feel for you and
uh you're gonna get through it and
that's horrible man and and I hate this
that this happened but also I will tell
you this much as much as it sucks
yeah your parents need to make amends to
you this is not your you know you did a
bonehead thing of course it's silly and
stupid but yeah and that's it that's it
that's where it stops dude I cannot
could you I cannot imagine what my sons
no you I mean this is you're there
that's an awful thing to do for a parent
that is so crazy I can't believe how
much religion ruins [__] like that you
know and I'm not saying all religion is
bad or whatever I'm just saying
that's horrible when somebody's that
that way about their religion when you
stick to whatever supposed tenets of the
religion or anything really but in this
case religion so much that you not only
kick your own office out of the house
but disowned them yep
for being a little bit of a horndog yeah
and sending
like
thinking obviously he got duped he's not
just going out there putting that blast
and the context matters you know damn he
thought he met someone that he could
trust that was dumb but he did like
what is that even like what is what's
even the reason what is their reason do
you think it's why is it just like the
family shame that would be the worst
possible reason it's not even a shameful
thing really like he's saying it's just
embarrassing I have a sinner and I have
no idea dude I don't know I'm not
religious but this is why people with
religion this is why people this is why
religion gets a bad name this is why
yeah I mean there are many reasons but I
mean there are many reasons but these
people are the people that give religion
a bad name dude it's all about what
happened to forgiveness
oh
the kid's got [__] booted out of his
house
also I mean he need right now is when
you would imagine that he needs you the
most needs you the most and needs people
support the most
how why it's just you know what it is
and this makes me even more mad they're
probably so like ashamed of their son
and it's like a social yeah I mean it's
not even like and they've got from
they've got demons too by the way if
that's the way they're acting oh dude I
mean God no God only knows and then we
beautiful we bring it back what I dream
about you that's when you really bring
it home but wow but [__] yeah dude God
knows God knows
God knows dude God's Bo Jackson in this
[__] your parents your parents are
going to hell for that AG double hockey
sticks send this to their parents dude
your parents send this to your friend's
parents
Mommy so convoluted mom and dad
both of you are going to hell double
hockey sticks and I can't wait until you
burn in hell okay well okay you know
you'll be screaming my name begging me
to come get you yeah and I'm not yeah
and I'm not coming so yeah okay
everything got so absolutely not coming
to get you okay okay I mean talking
about Kit Harington being in hell and
people don't know you screaming out your
name all right well I feel strongly
about it I feel strong about it yes hi
Matt love you guys so much
um Chris I've been a true baby since the
beginning I've seen you three times in
Nashville One in Atlanta Savannah I
think
um anyway my question is well it has to
do with my bosses okay so they're
British I thought you said Boston I
thought this was very fitting because of
last week's episode uh they're from
England okay
one of them lives here one of them lives
in England okay but they are always
talking [__] about Americans and it's
funny sometimes and sometimes it's just
like really annoying because sometimes
it seems like they really mean it and
they're not joking and um anyway
obviously I'm American yeah
I just don't know should I laugh should
I say something
um what do you think about this how
should I handle this it's just annoying
and so rude yeah
um I love you guys bye I mean if I was
you I would unload all of my true
feelings about the English yeah yeah
you're like oh we got better teeth
though don't we yeah they would be in
tears by the time I was through with
them because I got a long list
that's you yeah right that would be
great actually uh but the truth is
if they're English specifically English
then you got plenty to throw back in
their face okay especially right now
keep saying that but you're not saying
no I'm seeing in actuality you do okay
so if you what I'm saying is if you
really want to get down and dirty okay
in the mud still have dragging them down
you know dragging them down in the in
the dirt okay that has water in it that
is now mud still have not said anything
uh get muddy and dirty all over the
place and throwing it at each other okay
you have a bottomless well it's not
saying the things like what oh oh oh oh
oh you guys [__] just saying you can
say so many things right now they did
the biggest [__] bonehead thing in
the world if you wanted 11 said anything
nasty and dirty huh yes dude on brexit
unbelievable okay now we're getting
somewhere but you don't want to do
serious stuff like that well you know
about brexit
what happened
[Laughter]
okay well Google brexit well how about
that you know how bad it has been for
your country oh great Google it
I don't just saying
I don't [__] understand that well I
guess what I'm saying is it depends if
they're if they're jokes
you don't have to bring that [__] up or
are actually offensive yeah or if
they're just like dumb jokes if they're
dumb jokes just laugh and be like uh
whatever they're your bosses there's no
reason to confront them if they're
saying actually I can't imagine what it
would be if it was actually terrible
about Americans like whatever
could you come in here yeah so I just
want you to know America is for [__]
troglodytes you're a piece of [__] you
can't escape America you're dumber than
me because I'm from Britain you're a
piece of [__] you're ugly and I'm better
well I mean if that was it definitely
laugh if he does that definitely laugh
in his face ah [__]
um so yeah I don't know she needs to
send another video and tell us what what
they're yeah like how bad is it because
my instinct is to say do what you first
said which is just to laugh it off
because who cares if they're offended
you specifically that's a different
story but if they're just talking about
everybody talking [__] about Americans
including Americans like right there's a
thing you're going to deal with in the
world not me though learn to let it roll
off your back America well America
Trey Parker you can't sing America like
that without just straight up you know
what I mean so it's not even ah but yeah
it's the piss it's all good it's all
good but uh yeah dude uh I bleed you
know these colors don't run and I bleed
uh red white and blue so oh wow yeah
white and blue I bleed
white red and blue red white and blue
and stars sometimes that's so uh Stars
sounds so bad I scraped my knee and some
stars came out wow ice cream honey no
stars came out
okay well on a fire hydrant you did yeah
whoa seems like there shouldn't be fire
hydrants anymore like they should be
able to figure out a way to do it with
an app right you know what I mean yeah
2023 and we got [__] big ass red fire
harder sticking on the ground like
[__] like the size of my dog this one
was yellow so it Blended in with the
sidewalk right so it tried to hurt me
I'm gonna assume
hi Chris and Matt my name is Michelle
I'm a huge fan oh yeah um so I have this
friend who is joining a roller derby
team and she after she finishes training
she needs help coming up with a roller
derby name and she asked me to help but
I have no idea
um what her name should be
um some of the names that other people
have are like thunder snatch or like
ghostly Dave you know it's a weird
random names
um so I just wanted to know what her
scary thing yeah roller derby name
should be and if you are on a roller
derby team what would your weird
slightly inappropriate roles
Chris you should totally come to
Wilmington North Carolina I think you
would really enjoy it thank you
I'm confused if this isn't their name as
in like they get an alias because it's
fun or is it the team's name no they she
wants to come up with a name for her
okay cool yeah that's cooler then team
names doesn't matter Thunder snatch uh
what I like is like the way they do it
with like drag names it's like or
stripper names it's like it's like
or porn names too it's like a the pun
it's like a phrase or a word snatch but
the Thunder stats would not count you
know uh like I said don't know but uh
what's like uh uh
uh oh what do you what is that he's
doing
but what are you trying to say like uh
why am I playing on what these actually
are well but you're uh like uh it's like
a first name and a last name together oh
that's like a pun in in like like
Matthew Cox but like like a lot of [__]
my [__] my car right yeah yeah
um but for roller derby it's like you
want to lean into like the tough thing
yeah so it depends on what her name look
what maybe build it around her name if I
would honestly just be huge [__] wow and
then Here Comes huge [__] smashing into
ghostly Dave
oh no he's he smashed into ghosty Dave a
huge [__] just that's what I would do
because then it would like the way the
announcer would do it he would have to
say it like against the other person oh
no massive huge [__] slammed into
Thunder snatch they'd probably avoid
terminology like that not if it was
c-o-h C
what are you saying cohc that's how I
spell it so they have to say it it's not
car wow oh I see what you're saying
there you go it's like Loch Ness monster
cockness monster cockness Monster you
know that's a good one
cockness monster there you go okay
miles long there you go but it's a
female it's her friend as a female but
no they also asked what hours would be
oh okay what hours would be mine would
be yeah uh what I said
and then for a female
um I don't know like uh
fire hydrant
it will be cool if you're a redhead like
uh like something like that like or um
or Flappy titties you know would be cool
oh wow dude that may be a bad one
um there's something I'm trying to think
of hang on one second okay he just takes
six selfies and put it back in
just trying something I'm thinking
um yeah I I uh I don't know I think that
that would be a good those would be good
ones
um what I said here we go here we go
they got one here they chat gpt's making
them here we go thunder thighs Vixen
velocity Femme Fury that's a good one oh
like fanny pack there we go okay
Valkyrie Vengeance dude
uh Savage sisters Hell on Wheels these
are good Derby Divas Riot rollers Queen
City crushers
Dynamo dolls
yeah pretty good uh I mean they're
they're good though for chechi we need
to just whip that up real quick wow
gbt is very woke though it won't let you
do anything but how could you have an AI
That's woke they're just click that's
not that's not artificial that's not
intelligence they just design it more
and more so that it doesn't offend
people what they're struggling with now
in AI is like
like there was a period where like you
could learn how to make bombs
and so then but then they've included
words that are gonna maybe offend people
it's like you yeah it starts out as a
good idea obviously yeah and then
obviously it very just as obviously it
very quickly turns into a bad idea you
don't want people making mobs but then
also
they should be able to say we should be
able to have it say [__] or [__] you
can't even do that oh really yeah yeah
yeah that's bad man that is just the
development I think it should be no and
it's like America especially I think it
should be specifically your name and
then a plan words like like for Chris it
could be like Chris goes piss Chris piss
Chris Garbage Pail Kid piss awful awful
Chris or or like Matt in my case Matt
Fat Matt you know that's that's cool but
you're not fat would that make it better
or worse well that's a really bad
example because I would never use Fat
Matt but okay uh Matt the cool cat
remember when Madam mommy's call yeah my
mom used to go you might have to stab
because you know all the stats in a
baseball [__] and that was that wasn't
very creative honestly wow I didn't like
that why didn't you like that because
you didn't know that much no I know why
because it wasn't about you I mean
absolutely why that might be 15 of it
but the whole 85 of it is I could look
at baseball cards too and memorize them
I just didn't want to
but that means nothing the part that you
said at the end it means nothing because
if you did if you didn't if you didn't
do it I didn't do it then it doesn't
none of the things you said okay so why
don't you call me Chris funny guy or
something because you weren't that funny
I was funny as [__] yes I was and I am
no yes cause you weren't that funny boo
yeah but yeah okay all right all right
all right that's stupid did you see the
people your tattoos we're gonna put it
up people got the boy tattoos oh if you
really no I didn't push about it if you
really love me you guys would all get
tattoos well if you don't love me
started and want
only Strife for my family and try
everything I care about for the rest of
my life my time on Earth rapping then go
ahead and don't get it tattoo so uh yeah
man I you know how many [__] life
rips things I sign on people's arms and
they go get the tattoos the next day
you're not on tour so what do you mean
though people say can you write life
rips I'm gonna get a tattoo the next day
yeah wow yep
wow wow so you don't go on tour though
so you're not gonna have to do that so
that's actually cool to say because now
you don't have to do the work oh yeah
wow I mean interesting oh man that's
interesting wow okay that's what I do
now that's okay when someone's like it's
not good telling me something crazy I go
oh wow is that is that true oh my God I
can't even believe it oh wow
so I do at the end oh yeah right you
know okay how come Chino
Andrew here from Windsor Ontario uh I
have kind of a weird question for you
guys today and you probably have no idea
but
let's see what happens uh so I worked
for the city uh at the arena oh yeah we
have a guy who
or down syndrome per se and nicest guy
ever right don't mind hanging out with
them at work
but somebody gave him my cell phone
number and now he just won't leave me
alone
and tell me we're best friends which
he's an awesome guy right yeah no
problem at all with him with anyone that
much every day every day now he's trying
to get a hold of me and
without being me I just not sure what to
do I know what to do not sure if you
guys have any advice or you just want to
make fun of it but no I don't appreciate
both of you and I don't either I would
never make fun of this what I would do
is be that guy's best friend even more
than he wants to be my best friend and
seriously I I I would actually
I you know I would hang out with that
guy yeah you would but that's not the
advice you want he's in a position where
he doesn't want it to be happening look
within yourself and you might you might
want to yeah I would become my best
friend he would be so annoyed with me by
the end of the week he would be like I
don't actually know you know well relax
well no I mean I'm not trying to be a
dick but like come on dude you know they
don't that you can do an impression of
someone who has special needs and it's
not racist well it's not racist ever or
Prejudice
racist or whatever wow I'm saying I'm
just saying and I don't want everything
together
I'm just saying you can you can do an
impression of somebody who has
that thing whatever they talk a certain
way yes you can do an impression of
their voice okay well they either they
either sound like that or they sound
like
it sounds like Old English people in the
30s they sound something they don't just
sound okay what's up dude okay okay
you're not trying to be anyway right but
it's we all know it anyway
moving on from that uh in a week they
would be like I don't know okay but just
because I'm gonna do my own thing he's
not asking but okay but that's what the
best way to handle it in the if you're
you want him to stop calling you go full
on let's have a family with the dude you
know what I mean no what you do is you
you're what you do is what you would do
with anybody special needs or not you
can go up to them and you're like hey
man uh I don't know how you got my
number but like go ahead yeah
I'm the guy
but you know I'm a pretty private person
and like I'm kind of like maxed out
right now in terms of my time I don't
really have time to talk or hang but
like you know I'm down to talk to you
here like we always have be friends this
way but like you know I I this is not
it's not really gonna work out if you if
you don't mind stop calling me all the
time let's go car shopping tomorrow
that's how that would work
well if that's how that would work then
you need to be a little bit meaner
because that's someone who's not
listening to you but like you you have
to treat the person like you would
anyone at first and if that doesn't work
then you reassess but what he's doing is
he's giving like too much extra like oh
no what do I do just because the guy has
special needs like start out by doing
what you would do to anybody you would
think it was like off-putting and you
would nicely go up to that person be
like hey I I don't know where we got
like I don't know why you whatever I
don't know if you do things do it you
know right uh but yeah I don't think you
need to be like ah [__] oh no oh no just
because he happens to be someone with
special needs you know in all
seriousness you could also talk to his
parents or whatever
if that's an option yeah if it's true or
like a sibling yeah yeah I feel bad I
know what to do you know because yeah
that's serious yeah right right and I
don't want to disappoint the guy you
know right because it's true I make a
lot of jokes but that that's probably
how I would handle it yeah yeah
or block him and
anytime the first time you see him bring
handcuffs and handcuff them chain them
to the nearest thing that won't move
okay well you know or the worst idea
first one is best got mad at me for
making fun you need to do the handcuffs
thing talk about imprisoning the guy
um I actually would hang out with the
guy you know I know that yeah I would
actually hang out with a guy because I
would enjoy it and have it okay but I
like to hang out with whoever that's bad
advice as long as as long as I don't
want it the only kind of person I don't
want to hang out with is somebody who
thinks that they're too cool that's the
only kind of person I don't want to hang
out with otherwise I love it
I mean
if that's what too cool is
yeah uh I do know that you would but
that's again what a surprise Chris once
again making the whole thing only about
him well interesting you know okay it's
my podcast
all right yeah yeah um you're welcome
that's that's that's what you do guy
[__] oh wow hey crazy man
Ryan
[__] edit big fans
loved uh Matt Delia is confused and
congratulations listeners for a long
time
um we've got a question both of us have
siblings with uh children
um that are a few years older and
what is your opinion when you see
you know parents you know doing
something with their children that you
want to tell them like this is going to
mess the kid up or this is setting a bad
precedent or maybe yeah or making like
reinforcing like negative behavior or
like giving them something when they
whine I'm sure you both have some
interesting uh opinions Chris because
you've obviously got the two kids
congratulations on that thank you
um Matt as an uncle maybe there's
something that you see Chris and Kristen
do that you want to speak up yeah you
know what but um yeah now that he
brought it up keep our mouth shut
um should we speak up and be like is
going to mess the kit up what are your
thoughts
okay
it's tough It's So Hard to parent their
own kids but yeah I mean there is if you
see something like uh gratuitous like
you could maybe be like
do you ever wonder that when when you do
that if that if this would happen
because if I was a parent I don't know
that might that might is that something
that you think about or I read this
thing you know imagine even saying that
I know I know no good way to say
I mean I'm sure you know
your siblings both of you know your
siblings very well better than I like
what my wife does it to me right but
that's what I was going to say people
get
so touchy and sensitive about this kind
of [__] more than any other kind of
thing if you start even getting close to
telling people how to parent yeah it's
even like a thing like you don't tell me
how to raise my kids yeah it's like
almost an expression in America at this
point yeah you know what I mean like
true everybody's so like I know what I'm
doing you know and it's just like for
those people need to relax but the
reality is they're not gonna so I
wouldn't almost never do I recommend
this but I actually think I might in
this case
I made it up
that's the stupidest thing do you think
so I think it's gonna stick in people's
minds so I think it's great
leave alone leave alone a Japanese
teacher
no like I'm talking to kids or Japanese
children
[Laughter]
yeah that would be like something that
gets played over and over again in like
a 90s dancehall song
don't
eat no short short man you know it
really is all right you know who that
yeah of course you know who that
artistic
the artist's name is Gillette okay she's
a woman obviously uh there's a on
YouTube I mean it's so weird that I know
this there's a really underseen video of
Gillette playing I think she's in Peru
for like a Peruvian TV show in some
places some Latin country I'm not sure
but like there's like 12 year olds just
like going crazy and she's just like
don't want no short dick man
don't want no short dick man and she's
got like a Raiders jersey on and it's
just like it might be Panama it's I
forget what country it is wow but find
it wherever it is it's great bad right I
watch the whole thing at least 10 times
that's too much huh Brazil there we go
that's it
oh dude look at that
they're kids in the crowd only kids
dude zero Talent you know
also lip syncing it's it's literally
just she said it once and they're just
okay well we're gonna get demonetized
for this I don't want no short dick man
trip a little short dick so gross she's
a 10 year old dude shrivel
short dick man dude shriveled rude all
right enough of this you know this song
is so rude I know like that's so [__]
don't want no short dick man you got bad
breath you got bad style you are just
awful don't want no short dick man
ugly ugly ugly ugly
weird nose don't don't
below yellow teeth
you always smell like [__] dude uh just
so bad for you young kids out there
watching that song was huge dude yeah
radio Smash Hit always on this is so big
the opposite of short it was always
short short man on the radio on the
radio so like just change the whole list
so they made it about height
number one or short short guy even worse
dude don't want someone below average
height don't don't don't don't don't
don't
can't grab that can't grab the can't
grab the stuff on the high
need us to
[Laughter]
oh [__] he'll probably talks like this
[Applause]
dwarf dwarf dorf is his
oh man all right well yeah I mean that
is actually worse that's hilarious
there's nothing you would laugh at more
than that very true wow
um all right yeah I I forget what was
the question what the question was
I forget everything about it oh I don't
even know what the person was it was the
couple the ones that made a movie okay
best editing goes to it was for sure the
people who directed it also directed
another Earth
that one said that's 2006. so don't tell
him anything
no touchy touchy touchy no touchy don't
tell him anything uh yeah be really
careful be really careful and just maybe
don't you have each other like you can
talk you guys can talk about it
endlessly and get your [__] out yeah to
each other about one another siblings
and like that's super healthy for you
guys to talk about it amongst yourselves
but like
and I'm not saying absolutely do not it
might be better if you did but like it's
such a huge risk to take people are just
absolutely mental about their yeah I
mean your children you could try it once
and then see if they take too well if
they don't never ever ever do it again
to that person you're taking a big risk
even if you're taking a big risk you're
taking a big risk risk
um I don't know man that's a [__]
weird thing huh people get crazy
question though good question it's a
really good question because it's a hard
hard question
all right just remember though just
remember to not touching not touching
not touchy okay
Matt and Chris uh I want to know how you
guys feel about eating outside
uh when you go out to eat eating on the
patio or whatever you came by people I
hate it my wife loves it the reason I
hate it is because
one out of every 150 days it's good to
eat outside it's the perfect temperature
because there's no wind blowing
everything around the sun isn't [__]
beating in my eyes and just distracting
me and that's great cars making loud
noises so maybe one out of every 150
days it's really nice to eat outside
49 days uh eating inside is as nice as
you're gonna get one every 200 days uh
I'm interested to hear what you guys
have to say because you're in California
so the weather is pretty much always
nice but and yet so jealous uh we were
in Texas for a long time and now we're
in Kansas City and usually eating inside
is the best option yeah that's
definitely true I want to know how you
guys feel thanks it's I got I got two
things to say about it it almost makes
you wonder if he's heard you or I speak
about this before yeah I feel like he
did it for us because he knows yeah well
we don't like eating outside yeah and we
don't like eating outside because of the
temperature thing it's usually too sunny
or too cold or something the tiniest
cold wind will ruin ruins it a lot of
things but here's the [__] real thing
about eating outside oh
food tastes different outside stupid guy
thing to say no it [__] tastes
different dude you grow up eating inside
you get used to the air inside you open
your mouth the air goes inside you eat
the [__] the air and the food mix and
you get used to that taste you go
outside and you eat the same thing you
get the outside Breeze in your mouth and
you eat it with the outside Breeze and
it tastes different not what you're used
to and not as good and and that's that
you completely made that up no I've
always been thinking that utterly not a
thing though no food whether you've
thought that a long time or not
it's Mondo wrong it's not Mondo wrong
it's completely Mondo wrong all right
well there are two stand up for the
comments do do Foods eat taste different
outside okay but it is is that so many
elements are out of control no I don't
mean like oh so chaotic I just mean it's
not a control
oh
my animals keep [__] on me
it's everyone's it's not a controlled
environment like inside is you can
control the environment inside but not
outside wind bugs bugs are the worst
part you'd even mention bugs dude flies
how many times are you eating outside
going like this
yeah it's like it's like the whole thing
yeah bugs come yeah because it's free
[__] food for them here's why I don't
like eating outside I don't want to
share my food with bugs yep you're
eating it and I'm gonna if I eat outside
it can't help it and they they lay eggs
in your food and you eat them and then
the the Flies are born in your mouth
families of flies inside your body if
you eat outside your family it flies in
your body so that's great and then as
they grow your life ends and eight huge
bugs fly out wow and look what you've
done seen so much John Carpenter movies
look what you've done who's the guy that
did the fly to the world David
Cronenberg David Cronenberg is what I
meant uh
the better thing to mean because that's
it makes more sense yeah I know good
correction so it's fine all right once
again forgot what the question was yeah
I don't remember eating outside oh yeah
no so
it's not for me and dude it's something
that people always want to do because
they think it's a good idea and then
they don't realize when they're doing it
that it wasn't a good idea because they
just are they're hooked on the idea of
it but here's something that you don't
understand I figured it out here's
something that you don't understand I do
understand it probably you're not
always right because uh people who
aren't you like to do other things so
your biggest mistake and this is what
makes you an idiot right is that you
think everyone is just like you and if
they deviate if they deviate from it in
any other way they're like there's a
reason why
[Laughter]
long story short you're dumb no yeah
dude no yep
this is a fact of life you're done
yeah
I quit okay
[Music]
I quit Mr White there's still a dog on
me Mr White yeah oh isn't it Mr White
yeah
equipment right
I quit how much is that the worst acting
but the best act yeah you know what I
mean yep thank you Jonathan Shake how do
you say his name dude check shake shake
yeah
so many songs in this episode all right
you want to do another one yeah okay
cool he's not ready though right
what another one
in the game
yeah so I'm a probation officer for my
County hell yeah usually when people
come see me
they're not the happiest right yeah so I
was wondering if either of y'all had any
kind of one-liners
that I could use to kind of relieve some
of that tension during our meetings
uh Matt you're funny as hell man uh
Chris I'll be coming to see you at the
Altria theater in Richmond hell yeah
hell yeah and I can't wait for the show
man oh good see y'all
um I think the joke to make is a
specifically about what he you're
calling in about which is that like
everybody who comes to see you is so
miserable
so you either make a joke about how
you're miserable too or you make or the
joke is about how much fun they're
expecting this to be you know like
tampering down their high expectations
like I know you're excited to be here
but like something like that like like a
conversational not like a joke joke
though yeah but just something to cross
the road
so it's okay I thought oh those were two
separate beginnings of jokes yeah I
thought you were saying why did the
chicken cross the road and then the
thing about oh no the Jew okay bad
chickens love juice well it's bad anyway
so that would be bad is implicit okay
okay okay
um chickens
I don't want you to think I I don't want
you to like make a joke to these people
because they'll sniff that out they'll
be like oh this is a joke he says to
everybody yeah but if you make it a
conversational thing what the reason
they're acting like that is because they
think you're gonna be a huge [__]
[__] yep and ruin their lives for the
next amount of however long they're on
probation for yeah so at least signal at
the outset right that that might not be
the case so I bet you that goes a really
long yeah true and years ago you either
do that or you go full on dick mode and
this way it's so silly and that they
understand basically so it can go two
ways we can either do this and my
sunglasses stay on the whole time or
they might come off but what I'm telling
you right now is don't make me take off
my sunglasses but then where you been
the past day but they wouldn't laugh
because they'd be too like it's too much
of a risk to be like this guy's killing
kidding okay now check this out
you take the Sun goes off after that and
you do like some like kind of weird
thing or like you paint the eyeballs
yeah
eyeball Slinky things all right you
gonna make me take these off I'm gonna
take these off yeah take them off yeah
yeah and you're like all right now
that's just a little joke for you now
let's get down to business where are you
gonna pass
no let's get back into business then you
sit down there's a whoopee cushion under
your butt that's another joke for you
and then and then you say okay now yep
just kidding I was a whoopee cushion
where you been last day no I'm just
kidding now where you been about last
month's here anchor bracelet all right
cool let me download that info all right
come on
uh yeah I think at the beginning make it
I mean this is hard to do but as much as
you can at the outset like put you
together in league in some way even if
it's a complete joke but like put
yourself put him in your boat or make it
seem like you're in his about
this [__] like you guys are gonna do
this together even though I know you
think it's gonna suck or whatever
whatever you know uh
but the other question is then are they
ever not going to be super upset and
scared to be there probably not so you
might you're this is an uphill climb so
whatever you do might not work no matter
what because these are people on
probation you know they see you as the
man and their enemy uh yeah I know I
know I'm the enemy well just know I
could easily be in your shoes if I did
some [__] hating and [__] like you
did anyway where you been the last day
if I could think that's the last day you
know yeah yeah they only do it in day
intervals last two weeks where you been
bucko yeah you cross state lines or what
what's been going on don't make me take
all my sunglasses that's pretty good you
know what that he could do it it's just
normal you know what don't let me throw
up my sunglasses is from oh it's from
something yep no but couldn't act like
it's mine what is it
the officer says it in that Nicholas
Cage Martin Scorsese movie what's that
movie Bring Out The Dead yup oh Ving
Rhames does it I don't think it's Ving
Rings is another dude and he goes don't
make me take off my sunglasses I don't
think it is dude okay well we can fight
about it YouTube Don't make me take care
of my sunglasses is it like a bit player
yes oh oh oh it's the guy at the door
the big security guard yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude that [__] is so funny you're
right
I think it's that one
yep yeah that's it that's it
there it is that's so good play it again
that push in I mean the person making
that clip is just leave it dope alone
they have a seat to Doc be out in a
minute please
step back
I've already told you two to step back
please don't make me take off my
sunglasses
hi dude how did you remember it went
like this I remember the shot that's
incredible watches the line I guess
you're incredible uh you're incredible
I'm a brilliant type of guy you know I'm
just a pretty type of guy
um no I've probably seen that movie like
a dozen times though
that movie's good yeah you like how they
did the scene in reverse that one though
it's a cool effect and the stuff that
stuff in the middle is not my favorite
part but the movie's cool I think it's
actually underrated people don't ever
talk about it they don't I know it's
weird right even when it came out
Nicholas Cage was at the peak I know his
Fame and people were like huh it was
weird huh bringing out that was the
weird era for Scorsese because he had
just done casino and then he did kundun
and everyone was like what is this guy
doing then he did that kundun is the one
about uh the Dalai Lama oh
I don't even know that one so Casino 95
kundun in 97 then bringing out the dead
in 99 but after [__] doing it I was like
what is he doing also everybody hated
Casino too when it came out they were
like oh he's just repeating himself and
then he went so far the other way
completely doing something new was good
and everyone's like what's up with Marty
and then they put up bring him out to
death I don't love kundun but yeah I
mean it's all right
it's such a different kind of thing for
him it's like he chose it for that
reason which is always bad it's not good
yeah yeah not a good reason for choosing
things yeah but like all of a sudden if
I tried to like not to like I tried to
be like not like because my stand-up's
so [__] great you know I mean it'd be
like if I try to do something else I'm
sorry I'm missing I don't know man I'm
just trying to brag oh you're going to
you're saying if you try to change up
your comedy style if I just tried to do
something serious or something you know
like you're doing right now no I'm not I
I could though if I want to do like
serious acting right now okay what
happened
the boat crashed oh [__]
okay what the [__] are we gonna do it's
great
but wait till I'm like explaining the
whole thing oh okay you're not the boat
crash and it was carrying
both your beloved your wife and
all the gold that you used to own but
now he's lost at sea oh my God
my family's one thing with the gold too
wow yeah so that's what I was curious
which one was going to be worse the gold
the gold is one thing for my family do
they do yeah
okay then the butt is cracked why are
you saying cracked
it's they crashed the whole boat crashed
it's not that like part of it's probably
the writing then it doesn't have to do
with that ah okay got it um do we have
any more one more okay one more
what's up Chris and Matt bringing your
cardinal rule I feel like I'm driving
that's okay
Chris just saw you in Columbus great
show thank you came in five minutes into
your set not my fault didn't want to do
it did it anyway missed a few callbacks
Lulu and Denny said how you doing like
they worked there I'm gonna move past it
anyway my gripe is people using the
wrong terminology we were driving to
your show I'm from Cleveland it's a
two-hour Drive I was with my girlfriend
you wanted me to put on the windshield
wipers so I wanted to turn it on and she
said hey Pull It Forward she said pull
it forwards how do you pull something
forward so I pushed it and she said no
pull it forwards and I pulled it towards
me so I pulled it back and she argued
with me that that is forwards because
that's the way it goes but that's
towards the back of the vehicle just
wanted to hear your thoughts
I'm going to come again I'm a true baby
hell yeah dude Cleveland I'll be in
Cleveland soon explain you explained
what he just said he's saying he had to
pull it to him yeah that's the move he
had to do and she said pull it Forward
yeah you can't pull something forward
you push it forward you can pull
something backwards okay yeah he's right
he's right if she said I would have
known exactly what the person I don't
think I would have known I immediately
knew so that's how I know I wouldn't
that would have been of course it would
have been like you know what I mean I'd
be like I don't know you said forward
but forward is always pushing it I'm
right
that's what she should have said he's
right dude but I I understand he is
right but I always known I would have
known I think people need to be more
specific honestly in everyday life
no
you're stupid I'm not stupid I'm in this
guy's boat okay hold on if she's if you
were in the car with Christian and she
said
to do a thing put the windshield wipers
on pull that Pull It Forward okay you
mean pull it to me right that's what we
say
why
why would you have to ask
you know that that's what she wants you
to do yeah but because there's no other
option why you want me to turn it on
right you don't want me to turn it off I
would be like I don't know what you're
saying but why when you when you know
what she's saying when you know what
she's asking whether she's using the
wrong word or not if she just said
pull the lever forward I wouldn't know
what you meant if she said turn the
windshield on Pull It Forward I would be
like turn the windshield on okay know
how to do that what they were talking
about the windshield wipers she
requested it she said can you put the
windshield wipers on he said okay and
then he went to do it and pushed it
instead of pulled it and she said pull
it okay so what happens when somebody
says oh I couldn't care less
that means that I could care there's
nothing yeah oh yeah that's bad but then
they're saying but they're saying
they're wrong actually I think I could
care less I could care less means that
there's way more things right that I
could actually care less about I
couldn't care less which is the insult
which is that nothing in the world could
make me careless people say all the time
I could care less but really
stupid there you go and you wouldn't
want that who are you know what they
mean or are you people there you go yeah
exactly exactly I would but I wouldn't
correct them I would I would say just so
you know oh so what we're discovering is
you're an [__] I'm not an [__] I'm
trying to help them in their lives
you would say you're saying couldn't
care less but yeah to me you might but
you wouldn't to like just some person
you just met yes I would you would yeah
why
couldn't care less but yeah what do you
like what if I was [__] up like that
I'd want somebody to tell me so I used
to say supposedly wow supposedly really
oh thanks [__] you put a b in there I
mean I was young when I was 11 but yeah
just adding bees huh okay
right yeah
so anyway dude I I I yeah I would
all right you know I get a stuff to live
with somebody like that because it's
like I'll pull it forward all right dude
you know what I mean turn the [__]
thing on yeah but still my man's out
there doing the work well nobody do you
guys tell strangers that they have bad
breath no I've never told anybody they
have bad breath in my life really that's
on them dude I just stay away
I can't wait you know nah I've never
told anybody but by your life my life
but by your logic you should be telling
people that because you're helping them
people can't change my breaths sometimes
most of the time it's just like that
[__] halitosis [__] or did you smell
bad sometimes it's halitosis yeah most
of the I feel like oh dude no but you
can treat halitosis not can you actually
no you can't I thought you couldn't but
I have no idea an air freshener hanging
out on your [__] thing
um anyway I'm disgusted at this point so
I'm just [__] disgusted right we
gotta stop this whole thing is just
[__] all right what sideways you've
been doing most of the gross stuff
bringing up the gross stuff so I don't
know so it's all good look thanks guys
appreciate you leave a comment share
this podcast it's good dude share it you
know what I mean yeah patreon.com
Lifeline luxury sign up today we get
started soon and we drop new episodes
um at least bi-weekly uh you go on get
me on tour chrisley.com I'm gonna come
to Nashville a bunch of different places
do you have a question question click
the link in the description below or go
to watch lifeline.com or leave us a
message uh the hotline is
213-973-8095 I did it right if you were
paying attention I did it right great uh
whereas you did it bad in the beginning
right and then if you want one-on-one
advice with me
the Corduroy boy
mattelia.com
wow disgusting what literally talking
about [__] as I'm plugging myself go to
mattelier.com one-on-one sessions with
me with me
uh
uh and if you want a new merch the new
merch is beautiful it's comfortable
it's sexy
and you need to buy some or else you
hate us uh is at lifelinemerch.com it's
as simple as that you can't even forget
it thank you for watching thank you for
listening I love you I love you more
than Chris loves you and you all love me
more than you love Chris okay bye
[Music]
hello